yes it is Super Bowl weekend and that
means it's time for our annual Super
Bowl City showdown as the 49ers and
Chiefs prepare to slug it out on the
gridiron we're looking at how their
hometowns compare CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Michelle Miller went to
San Francisco and CBS Sunday morning
correspondent Mo Rocca visited Kansas
City so mo how was your trip
well good morning Anthony it was a great
trip it was great to be in the hometown
of the team that actually named the
Super Bowl when Kansas City met the
Packers for that first championship in
1967 the Chiefs lost that game but 150
years ago in what was their last
appearance San Francisco on the other
hand has won five Super Bowls which is
why no one really wants to see them win
again but since that's where Michelle
went well let's start our Super Bowl
City saga there
[Music]
[Music]
well congratulations Michelle you know
the Hallmark greeting card created here
in Kansas City is just one of any great
ideas to come out of the place known as
the heart of America the happy meal was
invented right here in Kansas City thank
you
Kansas City is also the birthplace of
modern American animation this is the
building where Walt Disney launched his
empire
that's right mo but the Walt Disney
family built their museum right here in
San Francisco can't say I blame them I
mean hard to be the view like this if
San Francisco Bay how's the waterfront
fair mo well the Missouri River also
known as the mighty mo is simply
spectacular thanks for asking but you
can find water just about everywhere you
turn in Kansas City known as the city of
fountains
yes Kansas City has plenty of nicknames
the city claims to have the most working
fountains in the world yeah we've got
some fountains here too but if you love
chocolate and let's face it who doesn't
some of the country's most popular
chocolate ears are right here in San
Francisco Ghirardelli and See's Candies
it's not
Oh Michelle that's sweet but when it
comes to really disrupting the candy
category Kansas City has you covered
that candy shell on every M&M it was
developed here at MRI global Hillary
would you're a scientist how do you make
sure these don't melt in my hand we
solve problems it's what we do go chiefs
how about this mo the fortune cookie was
created right here in San Francisco and
here at Golden Gate fortune cookies they
make about twenty thousand a day wait a
minute so I go like this I stick it in
here this is not easy
gee whiz you're like Lucille Ball okay
plenty of Chinese restaurants here
Michelle but the cuisine Kansas City is
best known for is yo whoa hey Michelle
[Music]
what are you doing in Kansas City which
Kansas City are you talking about you
know cuz there are two of them that's
right you're standing in Kansas City
Kansas also known as KCK I'm over here
in Kansas City Missouri also known as KC
mo you covered Missouri
I'll cover Kansas sounds like a plan now
where was I oh right
Kansas City is known throughout the
world for its barbecue and many people
say Arthur Bryant's is the best here at
Joe's Kansas City barbecue on the Kansas
side folks seem to think this is the
best just ask Doug we've got almost
everything that you can put in the
smoker on our menu no Rooter to the
tooter exactly our tally is where you'll
find murals that reflect the moods of
the artists who live and work here in
Missouri on the big screen
you can thank AM C for creating the
multiplex in Kansas the world's biggest
shuttlecock is on the Missouri side so
it was a great deal of jazz history
which flourished here during Prohibition
when the city decided to let the spirits
flow the era earned the city yet another
nickname Paris of the plains Cheers
we have history on the Kansas side too
mo school segregation ended when the US
Supreme Court ruled on Brown versus the
Board of Education in 1954 that happened
about an hour west of here in Topeka
well Kansas City Missouri is home to the
Negro Leagues baseball museum the Kansas
City Monarchs were one of the original
teams in that league and demora Smith
was a bad boy for the Monarchs so every
player in these are different bats that
is correct
that sounds really complicated it's it's
not because again their names on the bat
oh okay that makes it easy you very much
so the museum is celebrating the
hundredth anniversary of the founding of
the league's well if you need help
finding it or anywhere else you can
thank Garmin for making the GPS that
gets you there
it's headquartered right here in Cannes
well you won't need directions finding
Arrowhead Stadium since it's in the
Guinness Book of World Records for
hosting the loudest crowd and while the
stadium is in Kansas City Missouri well
kids the City Kansas is in the same
metro area
so you see Michelle we're playing for
the same team
she'll sorry mo I'm not in Kansas
anymore
besides once you've left your heart in
San Francisco you always want to come
back just like Joe Montana did he won
four Super Bowls with the 49ers before
playing for the Chiefs he retired here
in the Bay Area and for a city that
really doesn't need a nickname city of
Champions sounds pretty good to me
[Applause]
that was awesome well since Michelle
couldn't make it to the studio she sent
some fortune cookies from soon which I
suggest reading with a bit of skepticism
so fun she made these losing her cookie
over put in here the San Francisco 49ers
will crush the Kansas City Chiefs by at
least 25 points that's not that's not
the kind of ring I think this fortune
cookie is rigged many thanks